so i've been dealing with anything that
causes you guys grief
for 30 years here on the radio and if we
find something that gives you grief we
try to help you
with it if term life insurance is the
way to go we try to find a term
insurance provider for you
if getting a high quality real estate
agent is a good thing we try to do that
for you we do not
endorse things on this show unless we
believe in them i don't put my name or
my voice on something merely
for money and i that the most successful
endorsements that we've done on this
show are things that
have to do with a problem you have and
we connect you with someone
that is an advertiser to solve that one
of the biggest problems we've run into
over the years is people that are stuck
in time shares you can't give them away
nobody wants them you can't sell them
even for a dollar because nobody wants
to take over your fees and your
increased fees and all the hassles and
all the screw-ups
that we've been hearing about this
entire hour
so many years ago a couple of young guys
started a company called timeshare exit
team
and they were advertising on a small
radio station or two here or there and
they got in touch with us and said we
want to come on the dave ramsey show
because you hate time shares as much as
we do and we have a way to get people
out of time
shares we have a legal process with a
team of lawyers
to bust up into these guys and to get
them out
and so we said all right let's do that
however you guys are small
operators and you need to understand
when we tell people to come to you
you're going to get a bunch of business
and you're going to get your business
act together
to say that their business exploded when
i came on the air and told people
timeshare exit team will get you out
is an understatement their business
skyrocketed over the next few years
resulting in them getting more than 20
000 almost 25 000 people out of their
timeshares
but the problem was
they were so successful that two things
happened
one is there two young guys running a
business and it's hard to scale a
business that fast and they got where
they weren't returning calls that great
so we're jumping on them
because we're hearing complaints because
timeshare won't call us back timeshare
won't call us back from the customer
that's not okay and it was just because
of sheer volume of business
the second thing that happened was that
they were so successful
that the timeshare companies they were
feeling the pain
it was hurting them and so mike flasky
the ceo
of diamond which has just recently been
bought by hilton windham
mike flasky stands up in front of the
arda and says i'm going to commit a
million dollars to putting timeshare
exit companies out of business anyone
who comes at us to get our cut to make
us let our customers go
that we're screwing we're going to put
them out of business
we're going to do it with legal fees
we're going to do it with pr and
publicity we're hiring a publicity firm
we're going to put a team of lawyers on
this and he teamed up with wyndham
and he teamed up with blue green and he
teamed
diamond did and um
marriott and whoever else they could get
westgate whoever else they could get on
the list
and they decided to go after these
lawyers and different companies that
were running people out of timeshares
and they got they've got they've gotten
bad stories written about people
including they're going after me now
they've gotten
uh the attorney general in the state of
washington
to uh to try to prove that there was
something false going on and there
wasn't
and timeshare exit team although hugely
successful
over the years
has legal fees in the millions and
millions of dollars now trying to defend
themselves against this company
and they've run out of money they're
running out of money and so
they've had to pull off of our show they
couldn't afford to advertise anymore
they run them out of business they're
running them out of business they're not
out of business yet
but they're having to defend themselves
against the uh attorney general state of
washington they're having to defend
themselves against a massive set of
lawsuits brought
time and time and time and time again
and all they have done is get people out
of time shares that's all they've done
and so that's why you don't hear them on
the air here anymore
and then inside edition shows up and
ambushes me for an interview
and wants to know why i'm why i endorse
timeshare exit team
lisa guerrero and charlie well lisa
guerrero and charlie even though i
didn't grant you an interview
in your ambush in the lobby of the omni
at the dallas that was so low class
you too you ought to know better than
that
you don't think i'm gonna come back and
put 22 million people on notice how
scummy you are at inside edition
that was so low class so i'll answer
your question why did i endorse
timeshare exit team
because they were doing the right thing
and getting people out of timeshares
after companies like mikey's had screwed
them
that's why i endorsed that company and i
did it with great pride
and they got over 20 000 people out of
their time shares
before the legal fees and the bogus
stuff from
bogus government officials i wonder how
much he was paid
wow how much were you paid lisa
how much was inside edition paid by the
timeshare companies
how much did they pay you i didn't know
you could buy a story on inside edition
i didn't i didn't think you all were
that i knew you were tabloid
but i didn't know you were that low or
are you just so dumb
that you didn't understand you were on
the wrong side of this argument on the
basis of the consumer
so this is why timeshare is not on the
air anymore time's your exit team
but guess who's still on the air me
me and i'm sitting
in a 300 million dollar paid for
building
neck deep in cash you jerks
bring it bring it mikey
bring it you have done poke the wrong
bear
you done pissed off the wrong hillbilly
you have messed with me enough that i am
coming after you bozos
and i'm gonna make a hobby out of you
guys and you don't understand how
hillbillies work
we fight generationally ask the
hatfields and mccoys they don't even
remember why they're fighting and
they're still fighting
so diamond resorts hilton you made a
huge mistake
investing in diamond because i'm about
to destroy your freaking investment if i
have anything to do with it at all
i'm going to tell millions tens of
millions of people over
and over and over and over again
how bad mike flaschke is as a ceo
how scummy he is and how these companies
absolutely are screwing the consumer
over and over and over and over and over
again
if any of you dave ramsey listeners go
into a diamond
presentation after hearing this i got to
call you stupid
if any of you dave ramsey listeners go
into a westgate presentation after
hearing this
and you walk into the tiber tigers cage
in order to get a free pass to the zoo
and pet the tiger
hoping the tiger won't eat you you're
stupid i'm getting a free
a free hotel buy your own hotel
buy your own hotel do you hear the guy
called in in the first segment
22 000 he invested and used the thing
six times that's a nice hotel
where are you staying my god the four
seasons in paris france
i mean you can rent out the dead gum
come on people think think
don't be stupid rednecks and fall for
these people
don't be stupid these companies
are straight up evil they are sucking
the lifeblood out of america's families
and we have got to stop them from doing
it and the only way to stop them is not
legally
they got too much power because they're
buying off lawyers they're running
lawyer
you're that guy they're running lawyers
out of business
unbelievable guy's having to shut down
his legal practice
because he's overwhelmed with law with
court costs
and legal fees to protect himself
because he was acting as an attorney
to get people out how do you i mean 15
cases that guy's got right now
and that's just one guy you know how
hard it was for us to find him
we found him in 24 hours lisa it wasn't
hard to do a little investigative
reporting
and actually find out what's really
going on in this industry
if you were a real reporter
oh my gosh this is not hard you guys
this is not hard when something feels
slimy you know why
cause it's slimy
so diamond westgate windham
marriott bluegreen who am i leaving out
here
i won't leave anybody out just let you
guys know
you've been hassling my butt for two
years
behind the scenes and we just made it
public
game on boys game on